bonsoir les terriers bon sens les
terriens sonne le retour sur terre
toujours en compagnie d'estelle denis
[Applaudissements]
jean michel aphatie
et de françois damiens
françois le personnage que vous incarnez
vous permettre de composer avec votre
schizophrénie sauf si vous incarnez un
schizophrène évidemment on va y aller
vision va voir
[Musique]
les cdc
je m'occupais d'une pensée à ces
médicaments axel un je vous en prie un
disque dur en faut un ouais t'as l'air
bien toucher toi
cal droite approché des écoles
oui bien sûr j'ai le droit mais
le top pas le diable on va dire
tu t'appelles comment à la base ouais
françois françois comment damian
françois ou damien tu peux m'appeler
damien marley damian quand j'étais petit
je vous [ __ ] ses ventes à un accent
theekoye les formations de belges
mais c'est parce que tu es belge que tu
es là ils ont décidé de de tous vous
enfermez c'est vrai se créer une ligne
de train et puis nous emmène tous chez
vous le boulot à notre place était apte
à quoi comme traitement toi arrête
d'être trop défoncé
[Applaudissements]
taqwa comme traitement à manger à boire
une petite bière ah ouais et à petit
mais doc dessus de la tête ça va mieux
que les médicaments là ça commence à
aller mieux ça va mieux je me stabilise
ouais
mais c'est quoi pour toi allait bien
aller bien c'est
être à sa place ouais lâché l'info ce
schéma place à belle attaque est
ce que c'est le coeur à toi parce qu'il
me fait peur c'est celle à mal dit un
oui donc tu as peur
s'est éternisé là faut être fou pour
être acteur tu crois
bref faute un peu con je crois
tu es connu maintenant hein ça te rend
fou ça non tu parles tout seule fois
ouais beaucoup qu'est ce que tu dis
quand tu parle tout seul je fais des
tours en voiture je me parle à mes yeux
ça c'est vrai à lui si tout roule pour
rouler sur la fneje map en arrière et
puis je regarde le paysage qui défile tu
pense qu'on va te laisser sortir un jour
espère j'aimerais bien prendre l'avion
ce soir ouais ça te dirait qu'on s'évade
d'ici tous les deux après je passerai
bien un petit peu de temps et d'y aller
on s'évade dans l air
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de l'ina
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux